As all Marvel fans know, Groot is a character
who's more about action than he is about talk.
Possessing only a handful of words in his
vocabulary that can be understood by humans,
the tree-like superhero hasn't said much else
other than "I am Groot" and "we are Groot"
throughout his time in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
Of course, each line apparently has a translation.
"I am Groot."
"Whoa!"
"Language!"
"Hey!"
"Wow."
"Got some acorns on you, kid."
For example, James Gunn revealed that Groot's
final line to Rocket Raccoon just before crumbling
into space dust in Avengers: Infinity War
translated to, quote, "dad," because that
ending wasn't sad enough already.
And now, keeping up with what seems like a
new tradition, Marvel gave Groot another intriguing
final line in Avengers: Endgame.
Directors Joe and Anthony Russo revealed what
the talking tree-boy said at the very end
of Avengers: Endgame when they spoke in a
Q&A session following a screening of the superhero
ensemble at the Smithsonian National Air and
Space Museum in Washington, D.C.
A Reddit user who was in attendance detailed
the Russos' answers to nearly two dozen questions,
one of which regarded Groot and the final
words he uttered in Endgame.
The last place fans saw Groot in Avengers:
Endgame was aboard the spaceship Benatar,
watching as Star-Lord and Thor have a friendly-but-maybe-not-so-friendly
squabble.
The two heroes exchange some jabs that they
pass off as jokes before Drax the Destroyer
chimes in and suggests they "fight one another
for the honor of leadership."
After the other Guardians voice their support
for a knife fight, the camera then pans over
to Groot, who smiles and says, "I am Groot."
According to the Russo brothers, that line
genuinely means something: it translates from
Groot's native language into English as, quote,
"Yes, I like knives."
So, there you have it: the entire Guardians
of the Galaxy squad wants Star-Lord and Thor
to settle their differences in a down-and-dirty
knife fight, including little Groot.
"He likes to play with knives.
Very well.
We shall indulge him."
While Groot's final line in Avengers: Endgame
isn't nearly as significant as the last word
he said in Avengers: Infinity War, that doesn't
mean the phrase is completely without meaning
in its own regard.
Groot's last Endgame line leaves things with
the Guardians of the Galaxy on a happy, silly
note which, in turn, establishes the tone
for the next entry in the team's film trilogy.
Groot joining in on the banter with the rest
of the gang proves that the Guardians are
back in good spirits after Thanos' original
Decimation in 2018 and the reverse-Snap Professor
Hulk executed in Endgame.
The team may be without Gamora, who got tossed
over a cliff on Vormir so her dad could get
a rock.
But they've finally reassembled and are ready
to locate their missing member.
This last sequence for the Guardians in Endgame
teases that they may go on a search for Gamora
in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3, which would
probably benefit from having Thor in tow,
so long as he and Star-Lord can squash the
beef between them… as unlikely as that seems
at the moment.
"You know Thor?"
"Yeah, tall guy, not that good looking, needed
saving."
It will be interesting to see how the god
of thunder and the lord of dance get on in
the third Guardians movie.
Will their apparent rivalry dissipate before
it gets out of hand?
Or will it continue to grow until they have
no choice but to sharpen their knives for
a one-on-one fight, thus satisfying the twisted
wishes of the rest of the team in the process?
Star-Lord may have the advantage of his sweet
dance moves to shimmy and shake around the
hammer-wielding hero, and knowing Quill, he
might even play by Butch Cassidy rules.
"Rules?!
In a knife fight?
No rules!"
"Well, if there ain't gonna be any rules,
let's get the fight started.
Somebody count one, two, three, go."
"One, two, three go!"
On the other hand, Thor is a god who can summon
literal lightning.
If the two were ever to really turn their
verbal stabs into literal ones, Thor would
probably end up winning you know, as long
as he goes for the head.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.